mais écoutez vous voulez pas voir non
mais vous ne voulez pas voir la réalité
de la gravité de ce qui se passe dans
notre pays il n demure pas moins qu' y a
quelques années il y avait pas de
burkini sur les plat je sais que vous
êtes pour Monsieur Macron il en avait
pas et chaque année madame Madame Le Pen
vous serez gentil je vous avez déclaré
je ne vous fais pas parler je n'ai pas
besoin d'un ventriloc je vous assure
tout va très bien quand j'ai quelque
chose à dire je le dis clairement c'est
mon habitude alors que pensez-vous du
burkini monsieur je l'ai dit très
clairement ça n'a rien à voir avec la
laïcité parce que ça n'est pas cultuel
c'est un sujet d'ordre public donc le
burkini je suis pour éviter comme
d'ailleurs le piège nous est tendu par
celles et ceux qui veulent diviser la
société d'en faire un grand débat de
laïcité le piège dans lequel vous êtes
en train de tomber Madame Le Pen par vos
provocations c'est de diviser la société
c'est de faire que les plus de 4
millions de Françaises et de français
dont la religion et l'islam et qui sont
pour la très grande majorité absolument
pas dans le communautarisme mais qui
vivent dans notre République c'est d'en
faire des ennemis de la République et
bien moi non et donc le burkini c'est un
problème